is there something that everybody is
scared of there is I think the one that
everybody who has a healthy nervous
system will react quite robustly to is
if you start increasing the amount of
carbon dioxide that they're breathing
and reduce the amount of oxygen that
they're taking in that's terrifying
please don't do this because you need
the right proper medical staff around
but they're great experiments of having
people breathe carbon dioxide directly
you basically Panic it turns out that
there are a little group of neurons in
the brain stem that respond to levels of
carbon dioxide in the blood turns out
the reason we breathe is of course to
bring in oxygen and then offload carbon
dioxide but we don't have neurons that
stimulate breathing for oxygen we have
neurons that sense when carbon dioxide
levels get too high so if you hold your
breath eventually carbon monoxide levels
go up and then at the moment that they
reach a certain threshold these neurons
fire and Trigger the gas reflux so in
that moment you bring in oxygen and then
of course you offload some carbon
dioxide